- I'd love to leave you with
a little something to go,
and we like to call it (clicks
fingers) the doggy bag.
(audience applause)
(dog barks)
(man barks)
There it goes.
And today we're talking about a product
that I am a huge fan of,
and I hope you guys are gonna love it.
It, what?
(audience applause)
- Uh, Drew.
(audience cheering)
Oh.
What?
(audience cheering)
- Hello.
- Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Look who's here.
- Look at this.
- [Dr. Phil] What's up?
- [Drew] I'm so happy to see you.
- Well, I heard you were shooting
on the lot and, you know,
I've been here so long,
I'm like the welcome wagon,
so I brought you a welcome
basket, and you know,
your grandfather shot a
lot of movies here, right?
- I know.
- So I found some photos
of him on the lot here.
So how about that?
- That is so sweet.
(audience cheers)
- [Dr. Phil] Hollywood royalty, right?
- I mean, hello? That is so sweet.
- Yeah?
- And.
- You know, I knew that he was here,
but I didn't have any
photographic evidence of it.
- Yeah, well there you go.
And I've got something
even more special for you.
This is amazing.
You know, he shot one of
the most iconic movies ever.
(crowd cheers)
This is the original poster
for "Dr. Jekyll and Mr.
Hyde" from the twenties.
- [Ross] Aww.
(crowd cheers)
- I am, I'm going to put
these up immediately.
I love that you're going to be
associated with these moments
because you're bringing
me closer to my roots.
- You're welcome, and thank
you for being my friend,
and welcome to the Paramount
lot, do not park in my spot.
- I won't.
(crowd applauds)
- I will let you finish your
show and do what you do.
- I love you, Phil.
- All right, guys.
- Give my love to Robin.
- We'll see you, so long.
(crowd cheers)
- Well, thank you, Ross.
Thank you, Dr. Phil.
"House Calls with Dr. Phil"
actually airs Wednesdays
at 9:00 p.m. on CBS,
and season 20 of "Dr. Phil" airs weekdays,
and you check your
local listings for that.
I want to thank all of our guests,
and I feel so lucky and I just...
- [Crowd Member] Love you, Drew.
- I love you guys.
(crowd cheers)
Thank you for everyone
watching at home or on the go.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
(upbeat music)